Does the internet make
you angry sometimes?
Yeah, turns out that's
exactly what it's best at.
Anthony here, for D News.
And new research out of
Beijing University in China
showed that anger
is the emotion most
likely to spread
through the internet.
For six months in
2010, researchers
monitored Weibo, which is kind
of a China specific Twitter
with 500 million users and 100
million status updates a day.
They tracked updates with
different emotional content--
joy, sadness, anger and disgust.
And then they looked at the
fallout from those updates.
If someone tweeted
something sad, how likely
was it that their
friends would also
post something sad, but
unrelated afterwards.
Which sediments
got passed around,
re posted, or just
affected others the most.
The answer, anger,
by a long shot.
Sadness and disgust
hardly had enough
of an emotional ripple effect
on someone's social network
to measure.
Joy was slightly higher.
But angry tweets
caused a chain reaction
of about three additional
tweets within a social network.
I post something
angry, then my friend
does, than his friend does.
And we all do it without
realizing the influence
that it has on us.
Now, this was only
done on Weibo.
So we don't really know if it's
a cultural thing, maybe even
just a Weibo thing.
Maybe Weibo users are just mad.
But it does feel
like anger spreads
pretty quickly on
the internet, right?
Well, studying empathy
and emotion online
is a budding field with a
lot of early theory and just
a few studies.
But the findings so far
have been interesting.
Some studies say that the
anonymity of the internet
causes people to
leave angrier comments
and be more willing to
respond in an emotionally
uninhibited way.
But others say that anonymity
has never really affected
self awareness in
any other mediums,
so it shouldn't online.
We also use a lot of
visual and auditory cues
to understand somebody in person
that we just can't use online.
Stripping someone's tone
of voice or body language
away from a situation can
cause us to read more strongly
into any written cues, right.
So we see an angry word
like hate in a comment
and we imagine it delivered in
just the angriest way possible.
And it's in our nature to
heighten emotion and jump
into things.
We've talked a bit about
mirror neurons and our amygdala
before.
These are the bits
of our brain that
fire when we see someone
else doing something.
We use them to learn
about other people
and figure out how to
respond appropriately.
They create empathy.
So if we read something and
feel that someone we care about
is angry, that affects us.
But why doesn't sadness or
joy spread as fast then?
Well, in Trace's video
about internet trolls
he talked about
motivational reasoning.
How our brain is wired
to react emotionally,
long before the
logical cognitive
bits can even get involved.
And anger's an
emotion which tends
to cause impulsive
action, which might
explain why it spreads more.
Obviously a lot of early
research, but very interesting
stuff.
This is how we communicate now.
We should pay more attention
to how it's affecting us.
I try to picture
everything I read
online in the voice of Stephen
Hawking's little speech box,
because it strips a lot of that
false emotional inference out
of things.
And it also makes me feel like
Steven Hawking is my friend.
Does the internet
make you angry?
What do you about it?
Let us know down in the non
angry totally joyful comments
below.
And subscribe for more D News.